yeah uh
Nate Nate's claim of self-defense and
I'm gonna connect this to Islam and I
kind of I can kind of see his argument
there you know when you when you see uh
Jake Shields is the one that I know that
that you know yeah Jake Shields a friend
of mine okay um so he kind of came out
in in defense broke it down yeah I could
kind of see why I mean just because
we're we're we're professional fighters
he's still a human yeah and he knows if
a guy lands a punch on you especially
when you don't expect it he can knock
you out right then and there exactly so
you you have to be able to defend
yourself I mean one of the first things
about martial arts it kind of teaches
you is you got to respect that man even
if you don't know him even if his name
isn't as big even if he he's never even
fought before uh I think Nate showed him
the proper respect and if that was say
if that was Kamara uzman or if it was
Leon Edwards or or somebody who poses a
real threat to him coming up to him in
the same way I think he would handle it
the same way
because you have to stay out of you have
your Zone you have your space and in
self-defense you know you can't let
somebody come into your area because you
can get Sucker Punch you're going to get
hit so he was putting his hands up right
blocking yeah making sure and then what
happened from there the camera kind of
shifted you couldn't see but you can see
he started off with his hands right he's
blocked he's you know and it's funny
because you know one of my first kind of
things that that put me on the map was
was uh hitting Michael keosa when he ran
across the stage at me uh and I had to
explain it to Dana like why why would
you do that because there's a certain
zone between me and you and we know that
as men once you cross that that line and
sometimes the the barriers and uh
invisible yeah you know so for me and
him it was the halfway point of the
stage yeah so once he crosses that
halfway point you know you're on my my
side I have the right to defend myself
uh which in Nate's case yeah he had the
right to defend himself if he's putting
his arms up and the guy came within
armed reach and not be friendly about it
yeah then yeah yeah you're going to get
hit and he helped them out you put them
down gently he took a little nap
yeah
but yes
I did a little bit you know I think he
should you you he should be able to
defend himself yeah for sure and there's
so many people there's so much stuff
going on what are you gonna do and then
the guy probably may be trying to make a
name for him so he's in that zone
exactly but that was one of my famous
things before I mean uh not famous but
yeah well famous that's what I'd like to
do back in my day on the street as soon
as somebody comes to me and he's in my
face the first thing had butt yeah yeah
this is the streets this is this is an
MMA fight you know yeah uh so even even
the the letting them down gently I think
he did right by dropping them uh because
you you had he has to stay on his feet
you know this is a 200 pound man that
we're talking about in dead weight if he
goes down to the ground to let him down
gently you don't know if the guy next to
you is coming up and gonna sucker sucker
kick you in the head or something you
know you you gotta you gotta defend
yourself was that were they was that
like a party going on or something it's
like I had no idea I think it was Mardi
Gras so people just kind of party in the
street yeah but but and then it's it's a
lot going on it's yeah yeah Salon
protects you from all this
Islam safeguards you helps you to be
home at a decent hour explain it to me
explain it because you know a lot in the
Quran says don't come near Zina right so
now anything that can lead you in to a
situation that now for instance there's
a nightclub a Muslim really standing in
front of a nightclub there's alcohol
even sitting at a table where there's
alcohol these are the things that now
Allah wants to protect you so now you
don't fall into right it's not just like
when I just quoted this Ayah this is
don't come near Zina zinna is
fornication adultery and that so that's
why it's forbidden to be with the
opposite gender man to be alone with a
woman there's a saying a wise man said
leave a man alone an honest man alone
with a a suitcase money money be safe
leave him alone with a good looking
woman you don't know what can happen you
know what I'm saying so that's why the
prophet Muhammad peace and blessing me
upon him and said when a man is alone
with a woman shaytan is the third
shaytan is the third you get it the
devil's a third because now things can
end up happening right so you don't even
want to be alone with someone who's not
your wife or whatnot because things can
transpire things can happen you saw what
the whole metoo movement right the boss
alone with the lady and then all these
charts you're even as a Muslim you're
trying to keep a distance you know keep
yourself keep it respectful keep it now
same thing when it comes to other things
you know what I mean because you can
fall in Temptation can hit you know now
you end up in the white club now you end
up taking a drink now you're off you
know to me can I ask you a question
if so is it wrong for you to sit in that
nightclub then with in not partake
wouldn't that be kind of a a test
against your your your your your faith
in a test against your your discipline
um say it again to be able to sit there
in the nightclub have everybody else
around you drink and you not take a
drink let me let me give you an example
yeah so we have different stages people
have different stages of discipline
right but Islam when it comes is general
rules
for all you know what I mean like some
people will say because alcohol is
prohibited correct that's something
that's well known someone says but I can
handle it you know what I mean maybe the
other one person his level is is
different but it just takes that one
time that you end up drinking too much
and now you end up uh causing an
accident you kill the other person drunk
and driving no no I mean I mean for you
not to take a drink yeah so so now now
we go to that now for example this I'll
give you an example let's say you have
someone gifted you a or you bought you
work so hard to buy uh uh I didn't even
know this car before until I interviewed
uh Andrew Tate uh the the Bugatti oh
okay I didn't even know when I was
talking to him I was like what kind of
car is the Bugatti so let's say bugatti
because that's like I think uh five
hundred thousand dollars I think it's
like a million
yeah so I asked people I said look you
got a Bugatti would you leave it in a
bad neighborhood with the keys open and
the windows down would you would you no
no you would do that right of course so
our Iman is more precious our faith is
more precious maybe one time second time
third time you know you're in the club
or you're somewhere and you're
discipline but then that it just takes
that right honey or whatever you want to
call it it comes and that's it you lose
now you lose yourself you know and and
things spiral out of control so
prevention is better than chasing the
Cure you know what I'm saying so we know
what happens in these places the Angels
aren't in these places so it's the best
to avoid you want to be it's a different
feeling when you're in the Masjid when
you're around people reminding you and
you won't find people like bib or other
people discipline in this area but you
know I know you know I come from that
lifestyle I know and it took me a while
to go ahead and to this is myself but it
was different even just being in this
atmosphere without being drunk yeah
that's that's you know what I'm saying
yeah it's like you're talking a
different language yeah that's
definitely true yeah